although it's chapter one did a
wonderful job of capturing the
characters and the feel of the book a
lot of the novel's specifics were
significantly altered now that the story
is complete with the release of its
chapter two we have a more complete
picture of how the film's match up to
the book both the book and the movie
jump back and forth between two
different time periods nearly three
decades apart but while the book
alternates between 1957 and 1985 the
films are set in 1989 and 2016
considering the novel was originally
released in 1986 making the eighties
timeline filled tangibly recent to his
readers it makes sense that director
Andy mascetti and his team would update
the film to fill contemporary to today's
audiences although much of dari and the
story of it exists in what feels like a
sort of timeless bubble making the
decade almost irrelevant the modern-day
setting does alter the story in a few
minor but effective ways although both
the book and the film's focus on the
same group of characters in two
different time periods the film's draw a
much further line between past and
present with none of the adult versions
of the characters even making an
appearance in it chapter one
while Chapter two isn't quite as
distinct in its focus and includes a
fair number of flashbacks it's still
accurate to say that chapter one is
about the kids and chapter two is about
the adults this is very different from
Kings book which braids the two time
periods together streamlining King's
narrative likely works to the film's
benefits since it may have felt jarring
to visually jump between time periods as
often as the book does splitting the
films into a children's centric film and
an adult centric film allowed each one
to end with a climactic showdown against
Pennywise even if the kids victory would
prove tragically impermanent when we
first meet the adult losers they haven't
spoken in many years and the book
reveals what each of them has been up to
since they moved away from dairy I'll be
40 and far away from here I thought you
said you wouldn't be out of this town
through some of their professions
remained the same from the book to the
film Ben is an architect Beverley is a
fashion designer Bill is an author and
screenwriter and Mike is the dairy town
librarian but
if the losers professions were changed
for the film the screen version of
Richie Tozier is now a stand-up comedian
rather than a radio DJ and instead of a
limo driver chapter two's Eddie Cass
Branca is now a risk assessment analyst
in Kings version of the story
none of the characters were exactly
happy about having to fight it again but
still felt bound by the promise they
made as children in contrast the adult
characters in the movie are all
determined to leave Derry once they
figure out what's going on leaving the
town at the mercy of its and need to be
dragged back into the losers Club
kicking and screaming we never learn
exactly what it is in either the book or
the movies but both attempt to give at
least a partial explanation it is some
sort of ancient malevolent force that
crashed into the earth millions of years
ago in the spot that would one day
become Derry in both versions of the
story characters learn this backstory
through a vision but the circumstances
surrounding that vision are very
different in the films than in the book
the way King wrote it the child loses
attempt to mimic a native ritual that
been read about to try to induce visions
that will help them learn more about it
only Mike and Richey end up being
successful and are temporarily
transported millions of years into the
past where they witness its arrival on
earth however in the movie it's the
adult Mike that gets the vision through
seeking out a native tribe who give him
drugs that enable him to see the arrival
of it along with the ritual their tribe
used to fight it you torch me okay
another big reveal the book made about
it is the fact that it is female and the
version of its that the adult loses
encounter is pregnant it's probably for
the best that the film's left this part
out leaving it as a genderless ageless
entity the film feels more self
contained and definitive without the
sense that it might be teasing a sequel
in the book after the losers reunion
dinner at the Asian restaurants the six
adults decide to split up and move
around Derry on their own allowing
instinct to guide them the characters in
the book have a feeling that in order to
defeat it they'll need to get back into
the mindset they had as children casting
aside their adult tendencies to make
plans and follow their guts instead
the film while the losers still split up
their motivation is completely reversed
Mike tasks each of them with recovering
their childhood memories through finding
a token some sorts of significant object
that will help empower them to defeat it
having such defined plan seems to work
against the books insistence that
defeating it will require the adult
losers to embrace the uncertainty and
imagination of childhood in a big
departure from the novel Ricci is
revealed to have been harboring romantic
feelings for Eddie ever since they were
kids
in the book the adult Ricci is single
but his sexuality never really comes
into play
however it's chapter two spends much of
the film hinting that Ricci is hiding
his sexuality and Pennywise preys on his
fear of someone discovering the truth
Ritchie's big fear in the book is
eyeballs which is definitely creepy but
doesn't have much of an emotional weight
to it on the other hand Ritchie's
heartbreaking reaction to Eddie's death
at the end of chapter 2 helps drive home
just how high the cost of the losers
victory was and at the end of the film
Ritchie's visit to the fence where he
carved his and Eddie's initials as kids
and his smile as he traces the lenses
with his fingers hints that his fear of
discovery is now gone
killed with Pennywise in the book while
it does assume the appearance of
Pennywise a fair amount at the time it
also spends a lot of time in a number of
other forms some of these guises are
included in the films but several others
are either not included or are only
shown extremely briefly in the book it
appears to several of the children as a
gigantic bird and during the climactic
battle in the tunnels it turns into a
giant eyeball and then a massive spider
the film's did include a version of the
spider but cut way back on the rest
substituting them with new equally
disturbing Pennywise scenes such as when
the clown comes out of the projector to
the kids in chapter 1 the way it plays
with the losers perception of reality
was also altered for the films in the
book during the scene when Beverly goes
to visit her childhood home mrs.
Kirsch's house transforms into sticky
sugary candy playing on Beverly's
childhood fear of the witch from Hansel
and Gretel while the film just sees it
change from the warm apartment Beverly
had
de frst to the dilapidated building it
truly was this is just one of the many
changes the films make to its many
appearances while still maintaining the
terrifying sense that it can be anywhere
at any time
and we may never know until it's too
late in the book Henry Bowers attacks
mic at the library stabbing him in the
femoral artery and putting him in
hospital before heading to the hotel
where he's killed by Eddy in the film
these events are reversed with Henry
appearing in Eddie's room first Henry
then attacks Mike at the library but the
other losers are right behind him after
his attack on Eddie and Henry is killed
by Ritchie before he can do any serious
damage to Mike this sets up an extremely
different dynamic for the final showdown
between the adult losers and it since in
the book Mike is in the hospital and the
rest of the group is forced to take it
on with only five people one of whom has
a broken arm in the film all six are
present and able-bodied when they take
on it it is not the only ancient
supernatural force present in Stephen
King's book there's also an ancient
cosmic turtle which assists the child
losers in their quest to defeat it the
turtle exists in a sort of void outside
of our reality where bill interacts with
it and it gives him the ritual of charge
a battle of wills that draws on the
power of bill's childhood imagination
while the film's contain a few subtle
visual nuts to the turtle that's as far
as its involvement goes instead the
ritual of Chad is a native ritual which
involves the burning of the losers
tokens in a mysterious artifacts
chanting and strong belief it's
eventually revealed that the ritual
failed the native tribe who attempted to
use it and that Mike knew the whole time
the ritual fails and it is ultimately
the losers coming together to make
Pennywise small in their minds that
allows them to defeat it the town of
Derry is much more of a character in the
novel than in the films and it is
strongly implied that the town itself is
linked to it and sustained by the same
ancient evil so when the adult losers go
on their final quest through the sewers
to destroy it the town gets increased
more wounded dari gets pummeled by a
vicious storm and the townspeople begin
to awaken from its thrall feeling for
the first time as though something may
be wrong
the closer the losers get to their goal
the more Derry suffers with pipes
exploding violently and buildings
collapsing until eventually all of
downtown Derry is destroyed the film
keeps the destruction of Pennywise much
more contained with only the house on
niebolt Street
collapsing in on itself after the losers
succeed presumably the tunnels
underneath the town have also caved in
but it doesn't seem to have any impact
at all on the conditions at the surface
one of the strange things about living
in Derry in both the book and the films
is that once you leave the town your
memory of it slowly fades until you
don't even remember that you ever live
there a big part of the adult loser's
storylines is the effort to recover
their lost memories since until Michaels
none of them remembered knowing each
other or that they'd ever fought it as
children in the book this forgetting
effect doesn't change after the defeat
of Pennywise Mike ends the novel musing
that this forgetting must mean that it
is truly dead now and wondering how long
it will be until even his journal
entries are completely erased
however it's chapter 2 takes the
complete opposite approach is it a
bidding eachother sad farewells knowing
they'll never see or remember one
another again to keep in touch while the
film's happy ending is not as
bittersweet as King's it still serves to
convey that this time the losers were
successful and Pennywise is indeed gone
for good the tragic death of Stan URIs
by his own hand hangs heavy over the
characters in both the book and it
chapter 2 with his friends all assuming
that he took his life because he was
afraid however the film gives Stan a
last goodbye that the book never does in
the form of identical letters he writes
to each of the losers which he leaves
for his wife to mail at some point
following his death he explains that he
didn't take his life for the reasons
they probably thought he says that he
knew he couldn't bring himself to return
to Derry but that he also knew that the
cosmic strength that the losers held
when they were all together might not
reach his full potential if one of them
didn't believe giving Stan some of the
final words is enough
effective way of communicating that even
in death losers stick together but if we
stick together all of us or win check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]